hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing five spells
from The Wizarding World of Harry Potter
but before we get started I want you to
brace yourselves to the fact that these
aren't just any old five spells these
are five of the most powerful
destructive spells The Wizarding World
has ever seen spells so formidable the
by contrast even the notorious killing
curse of Vada cadaver pales in
comparison now within the Wizarding
World Magic can be leveraged for a wide
variety of functions from help with
everyday tasks like cleaning to picking
locks to teleportation but perhaps one
of the most important uses of magic in a
tumultuous Wizarding World that seems to
face a new dark wizard every few decades
is the ability to perform martial magic
that is Magic for combat now in everyday
context martial magic is not necessary
but it certainly never hurts to be
prepared for an invasion of Death Eaters
or dark wizard acolytes and that's
probably why most of these five powerful
spells were created in the first place
anyway I won't dawdle any longer without
further Ado here are five of the most
powerful offensive spells in The
Wizarding World 5. entrail expelling
curse the entrail expelling curse is
fairly self-explanatory it's a curse
that forces your entrails insides organs
to be magically expelled ripped from the
body the curse is incredibly lethal and
unquestionably it kills you a lot more
brutally than Avada Kedavra the curse
itself was invented by a certain
urquhart rack Harrow a 17th century
wizard that was purportedly A Healer
given that he is credited as the creator
of such a brutal curse I can only guess
that he mistakenly created it without
any sort of Nefarious intent in fact
it's theorized that the original
intention of the curse spell in this
case was to expel blockages from
entrails however somewhere along the way
someone must have realized the true
destructive potential of this lethal
curse rakhara's portrait is hung in the
deidal Lewellen ward in Saint manga's
Hospital 4. confringco blasting curses
in Harry Potter there are a variety of
different blasting curses that is spells
which produce a sort of explosion on
impact from reducto to confringo to
bombarda or all of these spells by the
capacity to do extensive damage
particularly if they're aimed at a
living thing however there are a few key
differences separating them with one in
particular being much more dangerous
than the rest reducto produces small
explosions that are more focused and
precise often used for blowing apart
specific structures or objects bombarda
is similar to reducto but produces a
slightly larger explosion and bombarded
Maxima is an advanced version of
Bombardier that creates an even larger
explosion capable of destroying thick
concrete walls the spell is notably used
by Dolores Umbridge in the Order of the
Phoenix to break into the room of
requirement but the most powerful
blasting curse of all is a spell by the
name of confringo similar to the Spells
mentioned above confringo is also a
blasting curse however what sets can
fringo apart is its ability to cause
almost well anything to explode in a
fiery Blaze the spell is particularly
useful against enemies who are hiding
behind cover and if it makes contact
with a living thing then you can be
certain that it will be blown to Pieces
the fact that this spell causes such a
massive area of damage and has the
capacity to blow up multiple people at
once makes it much more lethal than
Avada Kedavra especially if we consider
that the killing curse can be blocked
via inanimate objects but here's where
the real fun begins 3. Firestorm
throughout the Harry Potter books and
films Dumbledore demonstrates his
exceptional Proficiency in the area of
Elemental Magic on multiple occasions
notable examples include his Jewel with
Voldemort in the ministry Atrium as well
as his encounter with the inferior in
the cave but 3 through all of
Dumbledore's impressive displays of
Magic One spell was able to stand out
Above the Rest Firestorm also known as
fire rope but then through the darkness
fire erupted crimson and gold a ring of
fire that surrounded the Rocks so that
the inferior holding Harry so tightly
stumbled and faltered Dumbledore was on
his feet again pale as any of the
surrounding and fairy but taller than
any two the fire dancing in his eyes his
wand was raised like a torch and from
its tip emanated the Flames like a vast
lesue encircling them all with warmth
Firestorm otherwise known as lesue of
flames or fire rope is an incantation
that produces a large Ring of Fire from
the Caster's wand when the Caster moves
the ring of fire moves with them and
will effectively ward off anyone trying
to hurt them while the ring of fire
circles them the Caster also holds the
ability to shoot individual Jets or
balls of flame to their opponents this
ability pairs well with a spell by the
name of partis temporus which allows a
gap in the Flames for the Caster to
safely pass through Dumbledore used this
spell to ward off the masses of inferi
who were guarding the horcrux even in
his weakened State this Spell proved to
be more than enough to serve its purpose
they would place this spell well above
vadakadavra in terms of power
2. fiend fire next up we have another
fire spell fiend fire a vicious dark and
Powerful curse that produces massive
Enchanted Flames which incinerate
everything in their path the Flames
produced by the curse are also known to
take on the forms of giant fiery beasts
it was not normal fire crab had used a
curse of which Harry had no knowledge as
they turned a corner the Flames chased
them as though they were alive sentient
intent upon killing them now the fire
was mutating forming a gigantic pack of
fiery beasts flaming serpents chimeras
and Dragons Rose and fell and rose again
and the detritus of centuries in which
they were feeding was thrown up in the
air into their fanged mouths tossed high
on clawed feet before being consumed by
The Inferno basically fiend fire
destroys everything and the sheer size
and scale of the spell make it more
dangerous than nearly every other spell
in The Wizarding World 1. protego
diabolica last up we have protego
diabolica the most advanced form of the
much more innocent Shield charm protego
in its most basic form protego produces
an invisible shield around its Caster
that reflects spells but just a few
deviations away from this relatively
innocuous spell is protego diabolica the
most destructive spell in the entire
Wizarding World a spell that makes Avada
cadaver look like Bluebell Flames we
first witnessed protego diabolica on
screen in the crimes of Grindelwald
where Grindelwald casted inside of the
Lestrange Mausoleum protector diabolica
has a few levels to it but in its most
basic form the curse creates a ring of
protective black fire around the Caster
though it was blue in the film for
visual effect that instantly incinerates
any of the Caster's enemies in this way
proteko diabolica demonstrates The
Logical evolution of protego which is
also a defensive spell however here's
where it gets a lot crazier you see the
spell is not just a static circle of
flames it has an offensive component as
well in the film we see Grindelwald
controlling the spell like a weapon
extending tendrils of black Flames
toward his enemies these tendrils
incinerating Targets in the same manner
as the black circle
but beyond these tendrils the curse
escalates even further evolving into
what can only be described as a fiery
winged demon which causes destruction in
its wake it is mentioned that if the
Fantastic Beasts protagonists hadn't
banded together to stop this demon then
it would have destroyed all of Paris
seems a lot worse than the killing curse
to me and that's it for this video did I
miss any spells have I need to add leave
a comment down below until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign